unter sich wahrheiten aussprechen werde
selbst wenn diese unangenehm sind und
ich habe gesagt dass ich tun werde was
richtig ist und was notwendig ist
das war immer mein stil und das wird
auch in zukunft so bleiben
ich war mir sehr wohl bewusst dass der
weg mit der fpö als regierungspartner
widerstand auslösen wird
aber man muss sagen dass zum damaligen
zeitpunkt die einzige partei die bereit
war eine koalition einzugehen die
freiheitliche partei war
wenn ich jetzt auf die letzten zwei
jahre inhaltliche arbeit zurückblicke
dann tue ich das aus voller überzeugung
und mit großer freude denn wir haben in
den letzten zwei jahren inhaltlich genau
das umgesetzt was wir auch im wahlkampf
versprochen haben
wir haben es geschafft die
schuldenpolitik in unserem land zu
beenden
wir haben es geschafft die steuerlast
für arbeitende menschen deutlich zu
senken und wir haben auch geschafft was
wir versprochen haben nämlich die
illegale migration nach österreich
massiv zu reduzieren
darüber hinaus ist es gelungen reformen
in der bildung einzuleiten die
sozialversicherungsträger
zusammenzulegen und im bereich der
digitalisierung sind wir mittlerweile
wieder an der spitze der europäischen
union
und ich möchte heute trotz aller
vorkommnisse ganz aufrichtig allen
regierungsmitgliedern für diese
umsetzung arbeit danken
und ich sage ganz bewusst ich danke
allen ganz gleich welcher partei sie
angehören
sie haben wahrscheinlich aber auch alle
mit verfolgt das in den letzten beiden
jahren für diese inhaltlichen erfolge
ich bereit sein musste viel auszuhalten
und auch vieles in kauf zu nehmen
vom ratten gedicht über die nähe zu
rechtsradikalen gruppierungen bis hin zu
immer wiederkehrenden einzelfällen
und auch wenn ich mich nicht immer
öffentlich dazu geäußert habe so das
können sie sich wahrscheinlich
vorstellen gab es viele situationen in
denen mir das
sehr schwer gefallen ist das alles
herunter zu schlucken
ich habe trotzdem im sinne der
sacharbeit nicht bei der erstbesten
verfehlung die koalition aufgekündigt
aber nach dem gestrigen video muss ich
ganz ehrlich sagen genug ist genug
auch wenn die methoden klarerweise die
mich schon sehr eindeutig anteil
silberstein erinnern verachtenswert sind
der inhalt der ist einfach wie er ist
was über mich in diesem video gesagt
wird von beschimpfungen bis hin zu sehr
derben anschuldigungen und
unterstellungen
das ist alles eigentlich nebensächlich
was aber wirklich schwerwiegend und
problematisch ist das sind die ideen des
machtmissbrauchs die ideen zum umgang
mit österreichischen steuergeldern
natürlich auch das verständnis gegenüber
der medienlandschaft in unserem land die
fpö schadet mit diesem verhalten dem
reformprojekt und dem weg der
veränderung
sie schadet auch dem ansehen unseres
landes
und es entspricht das möchte ich auch
ganz ehrlich sagen nicht dem politischen
zugang den ich habe nämlich der republik
und den menschen in unserem land zu
dienen vor allem und das ist aus meiner
sicht aber das schlimmste habe ich in
den heutigen gesprächen mit einigen
vertretern der freiheitlichen partei
nicht den eindruck gewonnen dass ein
wirklicher wille da ist die
freiheitliche parteien abseits der
beiden rücktritte auf allen ebenen zu
verändern und ich glaube das wäre nach
den vorkommnissen der letzten tage mehr
als nur notwendig ich habe jetzt mehrere
möglichkeiten ich könnte natürlich es
mir leicht machen und versuchen
irgendwie die eigene macht
aufrechtzuerhalten ich könnte köpfe
tauschen und zu tun als wäre nicht viel
gewesen ich könnte einen fliegenden
wechsel zur sozialdemokratie anstreben
und damit ihn kaufen
man dass wir wieder genau denselben
stillstand haben den ich zurecht jahre
lang in österreich kritisiert habe aber
ich bin überzeugt davon dass beides
nicht das ist was unser land braucht und
auch ganz ehrlich für mich persönlich
wäre es nicht der richtige weg denn ich
bin in die politik gegangen und ich lebe
für die politik nicht um ein amt inne zu
haben sondern um etwas daraus zu machen
um auch für unser land einen positiven
beitrag zu leisten
mein ziel ist ein ganz einfaches ich
möchte gerne für unser wunderschönes
land arbeiten und zwar mit meinem
politischen zugang mit meinem kurs und
auch mit der unterstützung der mehrheit
der bevölkerung aber ganz ohne
einzelfälle zwischenfälle und sonstige
skandale
ich glaube dass das derzeit mit
niemandem möglich ist
die fpö kann es nicht die
sozialdemokratie teilt meine
inhaltlichen zugänge nicht und die
kleinen parteien sind zu klein um
wirklich unterstützung sein zu können
darum habe ich heute dem
bundespräsidenten vorgeschlagen
vorgezogene wahlen in österreich
durchzuführen und zwar zum
schnellstmöglichen zeitpunkt nur wenn
die volkspartei nur wenn wir nach der
wahl die möglichkeit haben auch wirklich
eindeutig den ton anzugeben
dann können wir die veränderung die wir
begonnen haben auch zu ende bringen und
fortsetzen und ich darf alle menschen in
österreich einladen die mit dem kurs den
wir die letzten jahre eingeleitet haben
die mit diesem kurs zufrieden sind dass
sie uns bei den wahlen unterstützen
ich glaube fest daran dass es in unserem
land wenn es regierung sein soll klare
verhältnisse und somit auch einen klaren
wählerauftrag für eine person geben
sollte die das land führen möchte
darum werde ich in den nächsten wochen
und monaten werben und dafür bitte ich
natürlich um ihre unterstützung
vielen dank
das war sie die seit mindestens 14 uhr
erwartete erklärung des österreichischen
bundeskanzlers sebastian kurz ich fasse
zusammen es wird neuwahlen geben es gibt
keine koalition fpö övp und auch keine
vp sp himalaya hat sie irgendwas
überrascht und es ist tatsächlich jetzt
die bestätigung dessen was wir den
ganzen tag eigentlich ja schon vermutet
haben an sich das letztere wir haben das
tatsächlich doch denke ich zusammen
richtig analysiert dass das die einzige
perspektive ist dass die spd nicht in
frage kommen kleinere parteien sowieso
nicht es gibt keine mehrheit dafür ist
beschädigt er hat gesagt sie sei auch
nicht willens sich zu erneuern so dass
also hier kein spielraum ist und er hat
natürlich auch viel selbstlob produziert
das ist legitim aber auf jeden fall hat
er klar im blick was wir auch gesagt
haben das ziel sei eben neue mehrheiten
für sich zu organisieren zu mobilisieren
das will in den nächsten monaten das
möchte man noch genauer wissen was das
bedeutet
dafür werben und da wird es eine will
eine neuauflage des dass das kurz
regimes genau was er hat ich glaube dass
mal auf märkte sagt er will klare
verhältnisse
wenn klarer klaren wählerauftrag für
eine person die dann auch österreichs
geschicke lenken soll
blicken wir mal auf das was sie dann
erwartet ein möglicherweise könnte man
jetzt davon ausgehen zumindest stand
jetzt eher würde er vermutlich eine
nationalratswahl gewinnen gegebenenfalls
mit einem relativ großen vorsprung aber
sind dinge in österreich wie eine
absolute mehrheit und denkbar oder ist
das wäre das tatsächlich im bereich des
möglichen
da denke ich erneut an diesem vergleich
mit ole von beust damals in hamburg
ja ich glaube an eine absolute mehrheit
wäre auch nach dem was jetzt vorgefallen
ist ich meine er hat jetzt hier oder
eine gute figur gemacht so war ein
auftritt und man kann das irgendwie
nachvollziehen aber es ist doch noch mal
ein ordentlicher sprung er steht ja ein
bisschen über 3 r steht besser da als
cdu/csu und aber es ist doch noch
ein weiter weg und er ist auch ein stück
weit beschädigt durch diese geschichte
denn er hat ihr die hand gereicht und
sie hat es sozusagen nicht goutiert das
ist schon auch ein schaden der den in
den der auf ihn zurückfällt ein
erklärter feind der großen koalition die
er über jahre kritisiert hat er ja auch
mehrfach eben in der pressekonferenz
gesagt welche optionen hätte er was
blicken wir mal auf die
parteienlandschaft die es dort gibt die
anderen parteien die anderen
oppositionsparteien sind ja relativ
schwach auch da wird es vermutlich nicht
reichen
genau also es ist natürlich trotz allem
was auch jetzt gerade gesagt wurde nicht
auszuschließen dass natürlich trotzdem
erneut und führung eine große koalition
sich anbahnt aber da muss noch einiges
passieren annäherung dieser beiden
großen figuren die neue sp chefin ist
auch noch nicht mit ihm in irgendeiner
weise vertraut kann man so sagen so dass
also die zukunft in österreich noch ein
bisschen offen bleibt aber zunächst mal
für den abend ist es in der interessante
bilanz die er gezogen hat halten sie es
für denkbar dass wenn norbert hofer sich
jetzt im wahlkampf als ganz anders
präsentiert wer ist ja vermutlich oder
auch bekanntermaßen moderater als
beispielsweise heinz christian strache
schließen sie aus dass er nochmal diese
koalition in erwägung zöge ich schließe
es nicht aus weil natürlich nach vielen
wochen und monaten einiges passieren
kann und norbert hofer ja an sich eine
interessante figur darstellt aber man
braucht natürlich einen ordentlichen
abstand zu dem was jetzt eben aufgedeckt
wurde und die musste ich tatsächlich
erneuern
ob ihr das in dieser kurzen perspektive
gelingt ist natürlich die frage in
seinem wahlkampf geht es ordentlich zur
sache das heißt also es wäre schon ein
stück weit ein kunststück wenn das wenn
man das hinbekäme wir sind gespannt ich
sage jetzt mal herzlichen dank für ihre
für ihre analyse hier am gesamten
sonnabend seit etwa dreißig sind wir
auch sendungen jetzt hat er ist ein
vorläufiges ende gefunden aber nur ein
vorläufiges denn um 20 35 erwarten wir
noch den bundespräsidenten von den
grünen alexander van der bellen
wird auch zur österreichischen nation
sprechen wir zeigen jetzt dass ganz
reguläre programm tagesschau und dann
die dokumentation aber diesen
vermutlicher sehr kurzen ausschnitt
denen zeigen wir ihnen
selbstverständlich auch noch live wie
gesagt 20 uhr 35 und bei uns geht ist
jetzt wie sie es nicht anders kennen um
20 uhr weiter mit der tagesschau ich
wünsche ihnen weiterhin gute
informationen bei phoenix
[Musik]
hier ist das erste